your single moms right do you feel like
it's fair to accept accept monogamy
um or to expect monogamy from someone
when you've given someone else a child
so they're not getting the youth and
like the Purity that they want I don't
remember I don't agree with your beliefs
so obviously I'm gonna say no I would
say don't pick me in the first place
yeah yeah I didn't realize you were kids
too yeah I have one child oh is it do
you me yeah okay
um yeah no
okay I think it depends on the guy
doesn't it like because if he's like
actually too fair if you said no then
fine but I think the higher value a man
is the more likely a woman is going to
accept that but if he's like just some
average or if you're gonna accept it
you're gonna accept that anyway not
because you've got kids not because
that's what that's why I say no I think
if a woman's gonna accept that she's
gonna accept that but I think most women
do accept it
I'm saying like how do most
relationships start nowadays
situationships side chicks
um like if you're in a situationship
like that's how most relationships start
is like talking okay and so I'm saying
like like most girls start that's what
you're starting as
I won't say me talking to someone
automatically makes me this I would
think okay okay would you say the
majority of the time sex comes first to
relationships which are six definitely
okay so when when you're having sex with
someone you're not exclusive what are a
side chick I'm having sex with someone
that I'm seeing yeah but I'm saying like
he's also sleeping with other people so
exactly so I agree with you on that that
I think you'll be very delusional to
meet a guy today and the first time
you've slept with him you think you're
the only person he's sleeping with at
that moment because you're just you've
just come into the picture I don't know
if I like you so he as in he's thinking
that I don't know if I like you I'm just
seeing where this goes and obviously
you've allowed me to enter your sexual
experience so I'm also going to
experience this while I'm here but the
sex is not going to determine if I'm
gonna be with you that's why I'm that's
why you should be selective for YouTube
and and when you allow him to access it
yeah but like the point is you still
start off as a side chick
for you to be aside you're going to have
a main right you have a main chick and
then you're inside and that's what you
can only be that yes
one of his side chicks is the main chick
at one point in time
she
she might not have the title right but
he has a favorite he has a number one
draft pick
you know what though I think I think in
regards to the question about
a monogamy when you
I would say
universally if a woman hasn't helped me
attain my high value status then she
can't expect monogamy from me um
she hasn't contributed to me I'm not I
don't it's yet because you have to
remember and I always say this like
women are born of value whilst men have
to create their value if I've had to
work hard and strive and do what I need
to do to attain a certain wealth you're
buying into that lifestyle having done
nothing so the only thing you can give
to me is is probably kids and whatnot
and again if I want to give you monogamy
I can but you can't expect it from me
because you haven't done anything to to
Warrant the last time but when you're 20
and or 21 or whatever and you start
building would you want to get into a
serious relationship really a lot of men
and I said this on the show as well it's
context um for guys who were in the late
20s building their foundations or set
their foundations they want someone to
contribute to their lifestyle
women that you're looking for a guy
who's already made obviously if you're
going for a guy who's 21 22 23 you
should expect a young boy's mentality
yeah I have a question for you go on
would you keep that same mindset for a
woman who hasn't helped you contribute
haven't helped contribute the time oh
sorry do you have the same mindset for a
lady who hasn't helped to contribute to
get you to where the level you are at
now
um but she doesn't have a child
yeah
[Music]
the point is that men like are
compromising on their mating strategy
but not getting their mating strategy
fulfilled in return and what is that so
they're they're amazing strategies they
don't want to pass on resources to
another man's kid like that's why that's
why they're repulsed by hoes that's why
they're they're repulsed by like other
people's children
it's like a natural so so women want to
lock down and get commitment from the
highest value guy they can we're men
they want Purity and youth and they want
to know that the kids are theirs so they
get neither and we get what we want so
you in a relationship
and anybody that you get with from now
are you going to be faithful to them I
haven't I'm close like high value status
in it so I'm still in the very I'm still
very much in my building but yeah yeah I
met someone now and I'm able to build to
attain that level then you deserve it
exclusively can I ask you a question
okay going was intense
let's say you
and who was willing to date someone who
had a child and you're in your growing
your building status and she was happy
and willing to build with you
would you be faithful to her
so I've accepted a woman for kids yeah
obviously in a normal circus and I said
that would happen anyway but if it did
and you know what let me just say I
think never say never type thing yeah I
think what what plays into my idea with
that is again it's the fact I'm Nigerian
and I know that would be even better you
know it's so funny you say that yeah but
in in Nigeria Nigerian men in Nigeria
accept girls with kids more than here my
parents are on smoke okay I know for a
fact oh does it come from like a
cultural thing so what I've watched my
own experience most mothers wouldn't
want yeah
from my experience as a single mother
right I get more smoke here than I get
in Nigeria really and I think and I
think a big part of that a big part of
that is because back back in Nigeria uh
a man who
who took on another woman's child that
wasn't his he gets a lot of honor and
respect for that whether that doesn't
happen yeah yeah I believe like back in
the day it used to happen but because
it's almost like oh wow he's the man who
not only is he supplying for his own
kids but for someone else's there came a
lot of respect for that so I think it
was more regarded in high regard but
it's not regarded like that today like
in Nigeria you can say that I'll be like
oh I've got kids they only think daily
joke that the American idea is like you
know you London kids like London girls
like to have kids quickly that is it
yeah but they don't they don't say like
oh you're less of a woman but they even
find women with kids a lot more serious
very much say a lot of the
responsibility if the if the family
doesn't go well a lot of the
responsibility falls on the woman like
it's the woman's fault if anything goes
wrong what if the marriage doesn't work
it's one of the reasons she's scared
that anything would happen in the
marriage obviously everything is good
but if it was she would say the problem
falls on a woman that verse still very
much sold the case like obviously modern
day women now I I agree with you I I as
much as is is a hard pill to swallow
the majority of the marriages that don't
last is because of the woman not like
she was the problem but she just wasn't
willing to show the blame no she was
just not willing to continue because
like if if I was to sit here and start
dissecting my marriage you'd be like but
you could have worked it through do you
know what I mean like yeah
yeah but and this is why I say that if
someone if you if you one of the issues
or the mistakes I made I didn't date a
bad boy I'm not interested in Bad Boys I
was it wasn't a thing for me I did I
dated the quite I was married to a quiet
guy but what I didn't pay attention to
and that was lack of knowledge is
attributes
mannerisms how you'll raise Family
Values all of that those were my
problems it wasn't oh he was cheating or
um you know he he was we just did it I
was just fed up it was that our values
didn't work together so that's why it's
my fault because you could turn around
and say that why didn't you pick up
those things but I wasn't wise enough to
pick up on those things can I can I ask
did you leave sorry yeah did you left so
yeah okay first yeah did you ever get
back with him no and you know we're so
mad yet you remember the last time we
came he said I don't uh you don't know
so in a figure of speech right when the
last time we came he said that um part
of a marriage um as a woman you're meant
to for your kids you're meant to stay in
a marriage but I remember I said it I
said the main reason why I left was
because of my kids because when you look
at my kids now they're a lot calmer the
teachers don't complain about them when
I was the teachers used to complain a
lot about my children's Behavior just
them being unsettled just being but as
soon as I facilitated structure they're
fine is that because you and your your
husband was showing the troubles in your
relationship to you this was even after
we broke up and he had access to the
kids as soon as that access was no
longer there they were a lot more
settled I but don't get me wrong I I am
so scared raising my boys because I'm a
woman
you know what I mean so like even little
things like when my son comes upstairs
and he's crying even though I want to
hug him because I don't want to make the
mistakes I believe some parents have
made on their sons I have to be Stern
you know what I mean and I I get scared
that am I confusing this boy that he
need a woman is meant to be aggressive
[Music]
it's like how do you teach him because a
lot of women don't even take that into
account a lot of women just they do the
the motherly thing which is just to like
Cottage yeah
because when I have a second question
would you take him back if there was no
other man on the planet no I'll probably
be on my own I've started to even though
I don't like it and I'm praying to God
it doesn't happen but I'm starting to
have that 10 that you may be on your own
for a long time
um do you think you'll have 2.5 million
saved up to retire
I think being same time you're 60. yes
if that's what I wanted I will have what
I want okay yeah I I one thing about me
and anyone will tell you I work hard I'm
I am a grinder well women like like
because the thing is
you're probably in a small percentage of
women that make that amount of money but
a lot of women will be homeless in that
position yeah and I don't think they're
really educated about that because I
mean I know there's like government
benefits here but you don't know
tomorrow they could take them away yeah
yeah
can I ask you a question to the ladies
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible